you asleep what
no
oh you
listen I have to get up early tomorrow
so
you want me to leave do you mind no I'm
cool either way
that's where I'm going
hey
you know
I actually prefer waking up in my own
bed
personal little quirk
you don't mind me not at all
good
so
it's worked out well for all concerned
yeah it was fantastic we'll have to do
it again sometime
absolutely
but not tonight
okay well
I'll call you
probably easier if I call you
sure either way I call you you call me
I'll call you
good
so I guess I'll just let myself out okay
finally
is everything okay that was perfect
Stefan thank you always good to see you
I liked it too
it must be a regular in him yeah food's
good and I bring a lot of clients
and speaking of which it's getting kind
of late I've got an early meeting
tomorrow oh okay well I'll get the check
actually I already took care of it when
you're in little boys room oh that's not
right no no it's fine I asked you out
it's no big deal no you shouldn't call
it the little boy's room
you're forgiven
so we can just go
yeah if it's okay I just want to go back
to my
okay I'll follow you
I don't think so Charlie I'm kind of
tired
okay well how about this I'll drive you
home carry you upstairs tuck you into
bed kiss you good night and just as
you're drifting off to sleep I will lick
your bunny from head to toe
lovely as that sounds I'm gonna have to
take a rain check
yeah I guess it is getting kind of late
it's almost nine yeah thanks for
understanding
sure hey dude we're okay right yeah did
I say something to upset you
are you mad at me no promise yes do I
sound like a big old girl mm-hmm
hey neighbor
hi Rose
didn't you have dessert with Sherry
did you know I was with sharing
I still don't get me do you
oh do you want to talk about it
no
she probably just had to get up early
like she said
unless her real date didn't start till
later and she just didn't want to eat
alone
what
come on Charlie double booking you
practically invented it
no she wouldn't do that to me why would
she do that to me
did she do that to me she did that to me
didn't she
[Music]
excuse me sorry I was just taking a
little selfish Delight in your pain the
Germans call it schadenfreude but here
in the USA we just go ha ha
thanks oh Charlie you don't need a girl
like that you could do so much better
you're right I can
she doesn't call when she says she will
she won't let me sleep over she's
obviously seen other guys so why can't I
get her out of my head
okay that's not where I was going
it's review she's gorgeous
also self-centered she's promiscuous
she's commitment phobic oh my God what
I'm dating myself
and one of the sex is so good
listen Sharon we need to talk
you're a terrific woman but you look so
hot tonight
really
[Music]
that was incredible
yeah it was wasn't it
it's funny how things work out
an hour ago I really wasn't feeling too
good about us yeah listen I gotta get up
early again
[Music]
um